almost anything I write the first time
through needs a lot of work I mean
that's just the way it is it's not your
best work it's the it's the first work
and it's a way to to kind of get it out
that is the process is rewriting and
rewriting and re-analyzing and realizing
rereading and rewriting and so to get to
be good at it
the process includes that so that
liberates you from worrying about is the
first draft any good now it doesn't
necessarily always work that way in
everything that you're doing when you're
when you're on a tight deadline
sometimes the process does feel Dr like
drudgery and that that could be anything
and I'm sure there's athletes that feel
that way about training but you do it
anyway you do it anyway because
eventually there'll be a time in every
session where you'll find the reason
you're doing it you're doing it because
this is what you do and this is who you
are not because you want to see a book
on a bookshelf in a bookstore but
because you are a writer and Writer's
right